hey there folks Chris waters here with
another overwatch hero guide today we
are taking on onna the first new hero
for overwatch who's available for play
now in PTR will tell you how to play her
later on but first Joey and I are going
to talk you through her basics how to
play her and how to be effective Joey
let's start with her biotic rifle rifle
is a little bit different than
widow-makers for example in that it not
only damages other players it also heals
them so if you hit your teammates with
it it'll heal them for a good amount
health if you hit an enemy target it
will take off a good portion for them as
well that's right ahna is the support
sniper and as such it's best to stay at
a little bit of range your rifle has a
good range and it has the that big scope
but you don't actually do a ton of
damage you're not getting it headshot
boosts like Widowmaker so you're not out
there to slay people you're primarily
out there to heal so you're gonna be
targeting your allies which does take a
little bit of adjustment the hitbox for
the rifle on friendly targets is
actually pretty generous so someone like
a Winston or Reinhardt they'll have a
pretty easy time getting healed by it
but if you have someone like an out of
mech diva running around as well as
shooting you're gonna have a tough time
targeting them tanks are a definite
target and on the other side in terms of
enemies supports are going to be the
ones that you want to target because
you're going to be able to move the
needle the most on them you're going to
be able to do a significant amount of
damage of their low health and then you
can finish them off using the biotic
grenade let's talk about this one
like the biotic rifle it heals allies
and damages enemies yeah so if you throw
it at a group of friendly targets it'll
actually heal a bunch of them at once
and also give them a healing buff for
about five seconds and throwing it out
an enemy target does the same thing
except in Reverse you have a little bit
of damage and also it reduces all
healing done to that target for you know
again five seconds the biotic grenade as
such is a really powerful tool for when
you are pushing because if you can get a
little heals on your allies get a little
damage and shut down any enemy healing
you're really going to help tip the
scales in your favor
so don't forget about this thing you
should be using it as often as it comes
up and as I said before a great way to
finish off low health characters and
also a great way to save yourself if
you're in a pinch chuck it out the floor
in front of you it'll heal you a
significant amount
it's very useful on in lock clutch
situations when you're running from
enemies and because Anand does not have
any mobility options whatsoever the only
thing that she can do is run and give
yourself that boost of heels is a world
of help smart use of the biotic grenade
can definitely increase your
survivability as can putting whoever is
chasing you to sleep with a sleep Dart
this is on as other ability it knocks a
character flat on their back and these
Z's comically come up from them and you
just imagine them snoring as you run
away get into a better position and
hopefully escape that danger
yeah the sleep dart actually lasts a
really long time for the first time in
overwatch this is actually true crowd
control it's not like macri's flashbang
or even mays blizzard where they'll
break free from damage maybe after about
second or two this one will actually put
them asleep and if you do not touch them
at all
they'll stay asleep for a good amount of
time it is infuriatingly long however
there is the key caveat that if they
take any damage at all
they wake right back up so using the
sleep dot on people that are in a firing
lane that are in a crowd where a lot of
your teammates are focusing their fire
is not the best way to use it because
they are likely to catch some damage and
just pepper right back up again
you want to use it when you're being
pursued in a solo situation and you also
want to use it to shut down enemy
Ultimates I'm talking Farah I'm talking
Reaper I'm talking McCree Genji shut
them down put them to sleep
and you might even get a funny line of
dialogue to go with it and not only that
the sleep part does give you a lot of
time to think about how you want to
dispose of the enemy if you put them to
sleep and you wait a couple seconds you
fire off a shot from your biotic rifle
immediately throw the grenade and then
maybe melee them that's almost a good
200 damage right there great way to
knock off a tracer if you can land the
shot now let's talk about Ana's ultimate
nano boost this is something that I
think has great potential to really
strategically impact your team's play in
ways that we haven't really seen before
because when you tag an ally with Ana's
alt it boosts their damage it decreases
the damage that they are taking and it
gives them a speed boost
so basically it turns him into almost
sound stoppable force you tag of
Reinhardt with this he can go running in
swinging his hammer without any worries
at all and maybe knock down maybe three
or four people at a time great way to
push with a Reinhardt Winston is also a
favorite because he can jump in and then
do that damage they'll be able to pursue
much faster than he normally can reaper
is also a great one easy application
there I also really like using it with a
soldier 76 alt I mean can you imagine
all that combined with the aimbot damage
dealers are probably your main target
for the soul mostly because they can
just go buckwild with it again G is also
another great option in the right hands
they can wreak some havoc on another
team absolutely so that is your
strategic overview of Anna a support
sniper who does best when she's just
behind the attacking force healing and
chipping away at those enemies and
giving those crucial nano boosts to help
turn the tides Joey folks in play is on
ax currently still in beta but how can
they do it well currently she's only
available on PC and if you want to play
as her just load up the ballon it
launcher choose PTR under your location
and just jump right in and good luck to
you for more tips on all the overwatch
heroes be sure to check out our
overwatch hero guide playlist right here
on YouTube and on GameSpot